Kim is starting off this hour in Florida
I cam how are you doing great how are
you Dave better than I deserve
what's up in your world well let's see I
learned about nine months ago that my
husband had acquired some debt I did not
know about I've always lived completely
debt-free prior to us getting married
which I didn't get married below is 36
and owned a house at the time and paid
cash from my car brand-new didn't know
about you at that moment but so married
and then you know 14 years into the
marriage I'm not sure what happened he
is a big follower of you and we've
attended two of your live events I
introduced him to you when we first
started dating and he's even taught FPU
before at our church in our last you
know place where they're living so I
live out of the blue that he had charged
on the credit card about $50,000 and
there were a couple of other credit
cards as well that he eventually
admitted to and he had also taken
withdrawal to Missouri and the amount of
about eighty thousand so needless to say
this is quite devastating to a marriage
and to me so so they are inconsistent
with everything else that you know about
him it tells us that there must be some
extreme thing going on yeah like he's
leading a double life for some reason
which indicates an affair or an
addiction or something like that what's
going on right I asked him point-blank
denies any sort of affair although me
being the person that I am I ordered all
the credit card statements and looked at
those and I can't there are things on
there that would lead me to think and
believe that that could have possibly
gone on well there's something that's
inconsistent I mean because he's leading
a double
agreed I mean he'd not only lied about
this and hid it it is an extreme amount
and it's not like he was you know this
is a guy who taught Financial Peace
University claims to live one way and is
doing things that are absolutely
perpendicular to that which tells us
there's some kind of extreme switch is
flipped in his head right
I would think no I will tell you that we
have made a big move and he had gone
through several job changes and had gone
from making into place of two hundred
thousand dollars a year to less than
half of that and in the midst of all of
that bought a house and I kept saying
let's find out exactly what we want to
pay for a mortgage and let's look at all
our investments and that was kind of
ignored and we we bought the home and
his jobs continue to change and not get
better and so and I mean while we were
renovating some on this house so he has
led me to believe that this was all due
to that and things were just kind and
they got out of control any typically
you're not involved enough in the budget
to know where all the current money that
he was making was going therefore
knowing it was enough right because he
picked over all of the finances which is
also - not with everything else you told
me about what he's been taught right so
have y'all heard y'all seen America
mm-hmm
well we started before I knew about all
of this and of course because that was
not based on all of the absolute trees
we had stopped seeing that gentleman
think saying well he's not really
helping and then I went back to my own
counselor and I have been seeing that
person and he has read a book and told
me he thinks he's codependent and I am
NOT he thinks he's codependent right I'm
not certain where he no no he's not
codependent he's a liar that's different
codependence mm-hmm he's a deceiver
mm-hmm I don't know what the root of his
deception is but that's not codependence
I mean he's lied and not just a little I
mean extreme amounts of lies and hiding
and has worked very very hard to hide
this from you and what's most disturbing
is not just that is that he that it is
so perpendicular to everything he
claimed to be mm-hmm and so it one I
don't know in my experience and I if you
were my friends and you two sat down at
the table with a cup of coffee was
sharing in me I would not be very gentle
with him I would have I would have been
ribbing him to shreds not because he
didn't follow my stuff but but cause I
won't I'm gonna try to find out where
the what's really going on down in here
because something some kind of a switch
flip that is not good there is an there
is an addiction or there's an affair
I'll give you a 90% probability of one
or the other oh yeah there's a gambling
addiction there's a honey on the side
there's a pornography thing going on
with prostitution there is something I'm
not trying to be melodramatic it's just
too extreme it's too extreme the
dichotomy of who it's so opposite and so
so perpendicular to everything we know
about this man until we learn this and
then he doesn't come clean right he
tries to rationalize it away and sweep
it under the rug which that tells me
more addiction than a fair mm-hmm
but I don't know I'm not a mental health
counselor I've just worked with them in
situations like this for 30 years and so
I can just smell these rats so on the
I'm so sorry
what a horrible thing for you all to go
through and horrible that he went
through this job loss and it led to
whatever this other thing is because
their self-esteem hit on all that it's
probably precipitated somehow but I'm
very much an alpha male
oh yeah for sure the self-esteem and you
know I want to help him whether we're
together or not I want him to be healed
and whatever day because well this is
the vote for you the normal a normal
mentally stable person in your shoes
would have all the same emotions of the
140,000 of hidden debt we call it
financial infidelity in our world
because you process the same trust
emotions being broken as if he had come
in and said he had an affair of the
secretary it is the same button to say
for you if you're a normal human being
and so what that means is is that you
need to get really good counseling and
not financial counseling but a good
counselor in your corner and if he wants
to engage in some healing with a quality
marriage counselor that a call out all
the BS that I'm seeing and you're seeing
in his life and help him start to clean
it out you guys have a chance of turning
this around gosh I'm so sorry I'm sorry